c'est le Hall of Heroes qui abrite les
artefacts de kung-fu les plus inestimables de toute la
Chine whoa cet endroit est génial
où vous pouvez dire que vous allez dire
génial parce que c'est seulement très
prudent tout est très fragile ici
comme l'urne de  chuchotant des guerriers
quelqu'un a cassé qu'une fois qu'un idiot a
vérifié c'est la légendaire bataille
rajapan pour le faucon douce balade ouais qu'est-ce que
tu fais nous ne sommes censés
toucher à rien
oh désolé désolé devrais-je le remettre ouais
tu promets bien sûr que tu as l'air si cool  bien que
oui c'est plutôt cool Oh qu'est-ce que ça fait je
devrais le tirer
je pense que j'ai juste fait pipi un peu n'importe quoi d'
autre que nous devrions essayer ici fils
je vais bien je vais bien ouais voilà